hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video
we're going to talk about is how to work
with circles and angles in circles so
we've got a few formulas in this
particular section so let's go over
those first over here on this side of
the board so we've got central angles
and what a central angle is is where the
vertex okay of the angle is right at the
center of the circle so you can see here
at angle one okay and you can see the
intercepted arc arc a B this minor arc
this arc is less than 180 degrees but
you can see the central angle here it's
going to have the same measurement as
the arc so if the arc is 90 degrees
angle one will be 90 degrees and vice
versa the next one you can see that
angle one the vertex okay is inside the
circle but not at the center of the
circle right so you've got two cords
like so they're intersecting inside the
circle and what you want to do is you
want to actually average these two
intercepted arcs you want to add arc X
and arc why together divide by two so
it's like taking an average and you're
gonna get the measure of angle one now
notice that this angle in this angle are
vertical angles so they're gonna be the
same they're gonna be congruent if you
want to solve for this angle here though
you would either need to know these two
arcs okay or if you know this angle you
can subtract from 180 since those are a
linear pair okay this one here you can
see the vertex of the angle is on the
circle okay see the vertex the hinge
right of the angle it's right on the
circle and that angle here is called an
inscribed angle okay it's inside the
circle but it's going to be half of the
intercepted arc so if this is X the
measure of angle one is half of that
over here we have a chord okay this is
the chord and this is the tangent but
again you can see the vertex is right on
the circle and the measure of the angle
one is going to be half of that
intercepted arc in this case I'm just
calling it X so the same formula and
then the last one we have the outside so
the vertex of the angle is outside the
circle and what you're doing is you're
actually subtracting it's the larger arc
minus the smaller arc divided by two so
this arc
sark / - this one over here we have two
tangents but again you can see the
vertex of the angle one is outside the
circle you're going to take this larger
arc or the one that's further away from
angle one - the smaller one which is
actually closer to angle one and then
divide by two so what I've tried to do
for you here and for myself just to make
memorizing the formulas easier is to
group them so you can think about the
central angle okay half of the
intercepted arc no okay I'm sorry
central angle it's the same as it an
intercepted arc inside okay it's an
average of the two arcs you're adding up
and dividing by two on the circle you're
taking half of the intercepted arc and
then outside the circle you're
subtracting and dividing by two so if
you can look at where that vertex is
located at the center inside but not at
the center on the circle or outside the
circle that'll help you to figure out
which formula to use we're gonna go
through some examples and you've got a
couple options here one option is you
might want to look at these pause the
video see if you can solve them yourself
and then go ahead and replay it and then
see if you've got them right or if you
just want to follow along that's fine
too
so let's see if we can go through them
so this one here what do we do to find
angle one well since the vertex is right
at the center this angle is going to
have the same measurement as the
intercepted arc okay which is 120 so
this one angle one is just going to be
120 degrees get out was pretty easy okay
this one over here now you can see that
the vertex of angle one it's inside the
circle okay but it's not at the center
so here what we're gonna do is we're
going to add up the two intercepted arcs
80 plus seventy okay
80 plus 70 and we're gonna divide that
by two so that's 150 divided by two 75
degrees okay with me so far now this one
over here is pretty much the same set up
okay you can see the vertex of the angle
angle one is inside the circle we're
going to add up the two intercepted arcs
we're going to divide by two okay so
that's 170 divided by two is 85 but you
can see that's this angle here so if you
want to solve for angle one we actually
have to take 180 minus 85 since these
form a linear pair so angle one here is
actually going to be 95 degrees okay if
we knew these two arcs we could add
those up and divide by
- but in this case they just gave us
these - so we worked with what we had
okay number four
notice that the vertex is on the circle
this is called an inscribed angle okay
and this is going to be half of the
intercepted arc so half of 80 degrees so
this is just going to be 40 degrees this
one here also the vertex is on the
circle okay you have a tangent and a
chord so it's gonna be half of the
intercepted arc half of one seventy
which is 85 okay we're just using this
formula over here okay and then over
here now you can see the vertex is
outside the circle we're gonna be taking
the larger arc - the smaller arc divided
by two so that's 16 divided by 2 which
is 30 degrees okay so angle 1 is 30 and
the last one here they give us this is
200 this is 160 okay so sometimes they
won't give you this 160 degree value but
you want to realize that in a circle all
the arcs are going to add up to 360
degrees that's the arc sum formula okay
and so we have 200 degrees - 160 degrees
divided by 2 so that's 40 divided by 2
so this is going to be 20 degrees so I
hope you're getting something out of
these videos if you are give me a thumbs
up like the video comments are always
welcome if you have questions or you
just have suggestions for making these
videos better I appreciate that you can
do that in the comments below and go
ahead and subscribe to the channel I
look forward to seeing in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon